[Musique]
alors que le premier ministre castex a
pris la parole hier soir et que les
écoles devrait rouvrir ce lundi
l'apparition de nouveaux variants n'en
finit plus d'inquiéter
après le variant anglais sud africain ou
encore brésilien voilà qu'un nouveau
variant fait des ravages depuis quelques
jours en inde le pays a battu un record
mondial avec près de 315 mille nouveaux
cas de kobe de 19 ans 24 heures
invariants double mutants qui suscite
l'inquiétude car il pourrait rendre les
vaccins moins efficace c'est une
question de jours et il est probablement
déjà en france
ce matin 20 étudiants étaient testés
positifs à ce nouveau variant se rendant
en belgique mais passant par l'aéroport
de roissy invariants qui progresse de
façon à celle du ranz ils ont été
immédiatement placés en quarantaine dans
leur pays il pourrait avoir contaminé
d'autres personnes durant le voyage
alors faut-il avoir peur du variant
indien jimmy pense que beaucoup sont
humbles on a dit beaucoup de bêtises on
sûr dit rien vous dire non c'est ça que
j'aime j'ai dit les choses devraient
donc pour l'instant du pape a prononcé à
se relancer mais toujours est il que
faut pas se leurrer le var y en a
certainement déjà sur le territoire
bien sûr un chinois qui a mangé un peu
angola donné la pandémie donc un image
inc avec 300 milles 4 coronavirus en
inde et les études nous disent que
finalement c'est probablement dix fois
plus donc très certainement qu'on a on a
trois millions de nouveaux cas par jour
est donc évidemment que le variant
indien va être présent sur tout le
territoire d'ailleurs il est présente
dans une vingtaine de pays
en revanche qu'on peut dire c'est qu'on
sait que ce variant étaient présents
déjà en inde aux alentours du mois
d'octobre est donc finalement il a mis
de nombreux mois avant d'être
majoritaire al'inverse du variant
anglais qui arrivait à l'automne et qui
a explosé en janvier donc peut-être
qu'il serait moins virulent je n'en sais
strictement rien mais il faut se poser
la question est ce qu'il est plus
dangereux si on attend on entend tout on
a entendu les plus virulents qui a
résisté aux vagues et voilà et surtout
est-ce qu'il est résistant aux vaccins
gaza et il a alors enfin d'angoissé les
français au fur à mesure où d'entendre
et fabrice mais je pense que c'est
vachement bien d'entendre quelqu'un qui
dit à l'heure actuelle je sais pas
et la question faut-il avoir peur non
faut pas voir pas faut qu'on arrête
d'avoir peur il faut se protéger il faut
il faut être prudent pour le
gouvernement prenne en place des mesures
qui sont celles de de préparation de
protection de com com mais mais je sais
pas s'il est d avoir peur la peur est
mauvaise conseillère toujours et ça
c'est important et qui donnait là je
voulais vous donner quand même sur
l'inde justement c'est à jean tout à
l'heure sur le mid sur le ministre la
santé indien gratuite est un truc qui
n'est pas inintéressant il dit divers à
travers le pays dans la lutte contre le
corona machin machin
j'ai dit que malgré la situation
défavorable aujourd'hui le taux de
mortalité de 1 18% seulement 1 75 % des
personnes sont en soins intensifs
tandis que 0 40% sous assistance
respiratoire donc on voit qu'on n'est
pas sur une explosion par rapport à ce
concours a rien à dire exactement ça
c'est pas rassurant pour nous mais c'est
en tout cas ça mérite d'être drôle
il faut pas confondre la peur et la
prudence mais il faut être prudent mais
pas être apeuré
c'est ça la grille de critères en fait
la prudence est une vertu d'accords
conseillère ne faut pas par confondre la
prudence à la prudence et une vertus
bluebird bio c'est la peur qu'elle a
besoin de conseils
bah merci merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions
fabrice burgaud et 28 sur un an il est
excellent il merci à la voix et de la
vidéo
fabrice di vizio je le trouve de plus en
plus sympa ah oui ah non mais vraiment
vous je sais pas ce qui s'est passé vous
qui 6 facile amoureux non je suis trop
vieux pour s'assurer d'une magnifique
gare à l on regarde moi c'est acheter un
nouveau cheval à a très bien un poison
est moche et maintenant c'est vrai et au
corps il s'appelle princesse princesse
alors on y va tu as mon départ oui tu
vas monter les bus tice est une jeune
bouliste eu droit l'an fig a fait un pas
de côté